sweden's hate registry
okay okay
jontron that makes sense he's a nazi
[Music]
no why
why are we still here
just just sweden every night
sweden my leg why my arm
why sweet and white
[Music]
lisa the government's database
has me
on the hate registry you are lying i
never hit you
you are tearing me apart lisa
did i do
what the [ __ ] did i do
why do you hate me sweetheart
what the [ __ ] are you guys doing here
rebel mode is over
get get out get out it's done
it's done oh you're here
oh god well whatever i'm starting my own
company this is a huge announcement for
me and
i'm hiring that's right
that's right i know this may come as a
little shock for everyone but i have
left the buzzfeed
uh i'm starting a new business i think
it's gonna be great
yeah i got great hopes for this one the
underwater rats
[ __ ] them okay i'm sure i can do
something with them in the future but
for now i'm starting
my new company but to start this new
company i'm gonna need some inspiration
on startups how do they do it
how do startups get millions and
millions of dollars
without really having an interesting
product or having like me
no product whatsoever let's have a look
here's a company that raised 120 million
million
let's let's look at their product making
juice is easy
start by taking a stroll down to the
neighborhood farmer's market buy about
fifty dollars worth of organic fruits
and vegetables
fifty dollars excuse me is that fifty
dollars worth of vegetables
what are you [ __ ] talking about
that's like two two whatever okay let's
just keep watching
what is this it's a juicero i don't i'm
sorry i don't know what that word means
it's a new cereal it's a it's a doger
oh i'm i'm sorry i don't i don't know
what that word means doger
can you can you define it can you find
that tommy it's a
it's a jojo doger
basically juicero is a 400
bag squeezer you can't use uh they it's
basically juice that comes
in packs and you can't use anyone else's
packs you have to use their packs
because if you spend 400
on a [ __ ] juicer that's clearly not
enough
now bloomberg did an interesting
discovery
incredible you can just squeeze
the bat excuse me
i i don't like doing this so i would
like to pay
400 please
it used to cost 700 by the way
incredible wow how much money did they
raise
oh a lot of people get so mad when they
found out how much i make and
just look at you just look at juices
okay god damn it i ain't making that
juice money
yet okay so calm the [ __ ] down and we
haven't even gotten to the most genius
part yet
that it it squeezes bags for you or it's
there's wait there's more there's
nothing to clean
no mess whatsoever it's so easy that it
makes the old way of juicing seem
well old why did i do all that other
stuff who cares that's our past life
this is our new life juicera
the easiest freshest most delicious way
to get juice
but uh i just got one question hey is it
a
dog though so clearly
clearly running a business has if this
piece of [ __ ] can
get 120 million i'm pretty sure my idea
is gonna get a lot more
than and a lot more than that wait is
this underwater rats
oh [ __ ] god damn it
oh
oh okay well it looks like i'm gonna
have to come up with a better idea
well as you know bus buzzfeed recently
changed their name from buzzfeed yellow
buzzfeed yellow is now boldly so now
buzzfeed is available
so welcome everyone i'm launching
bus speed yellow everyone
thank you thank you
uh
where the [ __ ] did he go we got a very
diversified
uh employee crowd of people so far
did i mention my dog is black
hello it's my lawyer what do you mean i
can't call it buzzfeed yellow they
they still trademark ah okay it's fine
it's fine okay
oh that's fine i'm gonna call it
[Music]
buttfeed
now that's stupid uh butt
feet
butt feet everyone so i'm looking for
i'm looking for you guys i obviously
need to hire a diversified crowd
so so i asked you guys on twitter to uh
apply to my new job my new company
butt feet i asked you guys to fill in
some simple questions and now let's just
review your applicants here we go
number one big mac ravioli what's your
best friend's age
87 opal ernesto
your gender apache helicopter that's
great
that's really great preferred pronoun
das
the [ __ ] does that mean if you were a
crayon what color would you be colors
doesn't matter
you're goddamn right and they don't
matter unless you're hiring for the job
i'm sorry you didn't make the cut you
[ __ ] idiot
colors matter a great deal all right we
have another
applications from mold dog another
apache helicopter that's great we need
one of those
if you were a crayon what color would
you be triangle
all right this is looking good so far
what would the name of your debit album
be kazoo kid volume one well that's
that's
clearly [ __ ] taking i'm sorry you're
out
can i get some serious applicants here
anything for views applied your best
friend's age 22
your gender male what are you [ __ ]
gay what uh
what what the [ __ ] is this preferred
pronoun legend
if you were a crayon what color would
you be white because
the white crayon is useless well at
least he's honest
describe yourself in three words fat and
lazy
anything for views you're hired
congratulations everyone
you're one of the first people to join
the the proud
butt feet thank you so much thank you so
much and we're proud to have you aboard
hopefully you can do something about
that gender but that's in the future
next applicant we have a my size 150
cream egg what would the name of your
debit album be
yo it's your boy's skin and penis
hey it's your boy uh
skinny penis wait your favorite k-pop
band is alba
you're up what the [ __ ] what's wrong
with you
god damn it griff the griffin if you
were a crayon what color would you be
kpop hair gray you're right
[ __ ]
this [ __ ] thing congratulations
the griff the griffin you're in buddy
look how many [ __ ]
apache helicopters we got
we got a lot of apache helicopters
applying that's really good
we need we need uh [ __ ] hell that's a
lot of apache
okay well luckily here we have a female
because we need
you need at least one otherwise
preferred pronoun lord oshimaru
is that that naruto [ __ ] guy zero
deaths
this is actually really promising why do
you want to work at mcdonald's i left
buzzfeed
yes you're in you're in buddy
we have gathered the team of butt feed
congratulations you start
uh right now get the [ __ ] to work i
don't know
paying
what is this video about we need a logo
for this endeavor let's just make one
uh right now we need a logo for butt
feet all right so we have a
we have a butt here and uh now we're
slowly
slowly gonna make sure that it's uh
yes yes that's it
butt feed butt feet everyone there it is
excellent we're gonna make millions i
wonder how much buzzfeed is worth
actually
oh my [ __ ] god
[Music]
how am i gonna get funding even though
i'm a rich millionaire that's just
ridiculous
i could start a patreon kanye west as
mark zuckerberg for one billion mark
zuckerberg
invest one billion dollar into kanye
west ideas okay well let's just
all right well that pretty much does it
that thank you
thank you we we got the funding we got
the shitty idea we got the name
and we got the applicants